>>> Today, president Biden
revealed he told the Pentagon on
Wednesday to shoot down the
Chinese balloon as soon as it
was safe to do so.
But there is still plenty of
partisan sniping.
J.D. Vance adding to tweet and
photo, and saying now he won't
defend our skies and Marjorie
Taylor green saying, it would be
great if average Joe would shoot
it down.
Because Joe won't.
Joining us now, Molly Jong.
This is not exactly shooting
beer bottles of your grand
daddy's back porch.
I think today we saw the U.S.
Military handling it in a very
professional way.
It's really how it should end.
>> Yeah, this is really such a
nonevent.
It feels like it was invented by
the fox and friends weekend crew
who wanted something to be mad
at.
Joe Biden did exactly what he
should do is trust his experts
and advisers and not endanger
American lives.
And when you put it next to the
former guy who literally had his
guys storm the capitol armed to
overturn the election, it seems
absurd that the partisan bickers
will
>> Molly, the president was very
emphatic earlier this and made
it clear he gave this order on
Wednesday to shoot it down as
soon as it was safe to do so.
>> This is like the outrage
machine and these Maga
Republicans love guns so they've
decided when you love guns so
much, everything, you know, if
you only have a hammer,
everything is a nail.
And so they're talking about
guns shooting down a Chinese spy
balloon that they could never
reach.
This is not a job for guns.
This is a job for larger
weapons.
And the reality is these
Republicans have just decided
that they can use it to sort of
promote their pro gun agenda.
This week, we saw members of
congress, Republican members of
congress, wearing little assault
rifle pins.
This is the fetesization of guns
and it's not about anything
real.
>> Yeah, there was a local
sheriff who put out a tweet
today who said please don't
shoot up into the sky at the
balloon.
It's 60,000 feet in the air.
You're not going to hit it.
Se, let's shift to some
important news.
Earlier in the afternoon in the
presidential primaries on when
they should be held, the
Democrats have approved the
shakeup of the 2024 primary
calendar.
I guess it's far from a done
deal just yet, but what do you
think?
Could this impact GOP primaries?
I mean, it's pretty, I think
it's pretty important that south
Carolina's going to be going
first it looks like instead of
Iowa.
>> I think it will.
If you're a normal candidate.
If you're a normal candidate, I
think it will absolutely affect
your calendar.
Your timing.
And your get out the vote
machine.
The only, I'll remind you, the
only person who has announced is
Donald Trump other than Steve
Laffey, the former mayor of
Rhode Island.
Trump's the only one who's
announced.
So for trump, I don't think this
matters at all because he's not
a conventional candidate.
He doesn't care about the
calendar.
His get out the vote machine is
Twitter and truth social and his
rallies.
It really depends on who gets in
the race and when.
>> And Molly, on the Republican
side although a half dozen or so
potential candidates have
dropped hints, looks like Nicki
Hailey will be the first to take
on Donald Trump.
You wrote about trump's campaign
and how it's anything but normal
at this point.
What stands out to you when it
comes to not normal?
>> He's trying to sort of
channel a Jeb Bush normal style
campaign rallies as opposed to
these like huge Maga rallies
that he used to have with all
these people following him
around.
I think ultimately, it comes,
you know, it falls on us to
remind us that this person has
multiple investigations, that he
has incited this insurrection.
So far, everyone has been
punished including his CEO, but
he himself has not.
I think that that's an odd place
to be.
Right now, he still is the
Republican front-runner.
So I think it's hard to cover
him but I do think the one thing
that is good is he's not going
to have all the free media he